ce que vous aimez la messagerie armes
oui avec ce je vous laisse entre ses
mains isabelle morini bosc
j'ai vu ta photo wikipedia royaume hassa
tes lunettes
elles sont plus grosses que ma télé on
dirait la fiche d'alcool qui sans
déconner tu t'es plus prompt et fils
d'ailleurs ça c'est des lunettes pour le
tour de france
alors la prochaine fois que tu fort ça
en public que tu portes pas un maillot
avec marc et justin bridou leclerc au
casino je te fous au frais merde
d'ailleurs on va continuer sur ton style
c'est pas homologué tous les canettes de
coca sa sommet dans la poubelle jaune
pas de cette oreille
et puis c'est quoi ces bijoux regarde
alors toi tu vas pas en bijouterie tu
vas directement rayon légumes du
supermarché bas mais elle porte des
piments autour du cou
pourquoi tu fais ça tu compte préparer
une salade méchouia hanouna pendant la
coupure pub vient regarde tes fesses à
l'aide je connais des clubs tunisiens du
parti quinze jours à marrakech les
vaches limite mal je suis pas un
imitateur salle el mouggar la bagarre
mais sa voix si tu colles des tartes à
verdez en même temps comme thème le
badminton ex ans et ressemble à un
volant tu as dit que tu tiens je vais
attaquer une partie
tu dis que vous faites l'amour tous les
samedis matins avant d'aller au marché
avec ton arrive et vous appelez ça faire
panna cotta garde bien pour toi le jour
où vos fêtes mousse au chocolat
[Musique]
excusez moi on n'est pas sûr que oui
vous êtes sûr que j'ai même pas 6 a
compris entre vous êtes choqué j'ai le
centre devient moche plus faut attirer
l'attention ce n'est pas l'or le jeudi
je trouve magnifique
voilà une émission d'humour alors
censeurs je suis sincère